don't work around many dogs so it's a
challenge keeping safety a priority at
all cost
Andy's taking his dogs around this lake
we're gonna use a snowmobile to get a
cool kind of slow-motion shot we're
gonna do shots of Andy and the dogs and
the only way we've been able to figure
out house we're gonna sit inside this
sled that we've made
attaboys
just seeing how close they'll get to the
sled okay let's go we had a little
problem the Dodge they're skittish
around a snow ball things are gonna be
ran over by a snowmobile we're actually
going to Corrine maneuver hey Jeremiah
ahead boy straight ahead let's go good
it went well we were getting pretty
amazing shots for sure we're gonna go
home okay let's go
all right good run now boys Jack the dog
twice it needs to be dry-cleaned can't
get the treat for marking turf die I
have an experience sort of flying so I
don't know what to gauge dangerous off
of we are shuttling all of our equipment
and Eagle to shoot some episodes we're
coming in on a little plane there's like
a lot of wind and it's really gusty so I
was pretty scared
not everybody's in here we've got three
of us in but waiting on Jeremiah to get
in but the sun's going down and the
winds are picking up which makes it
really dangerous turbulence is crazy
quite bumpy you hit the wind's coming up
off the mountains and you literally drop
there's a whole stomach just falls
dropping like 50 100 feet it's
frightening that one looks a little
freaky ugh look at your hovering for
something like that up and down inside I
wasn't even sure whether he was flying
him anymore fun flight in the wind
you